Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see if a virtual AI
character can learn, or perhaps even invent
these amazing signature moves.
And this is a paper that was written by Sebastian
Starke and his colleagues.
He is a recurring scientist on this series,
for instance, earlier he wrote this magnificent
paper about Dribbling AI characters.
Look.
The key challenge here was that we were given
only 3 hours of unstructured motion capture
data.
That is next to nothing, and from this next
to nothing, it not only learned these motions
really well, but it could weave them together,
even when a specific movement combination
was not present in this training data.
But, as these motions are created by human
animators, and may show at least three problems.
One, the training data may contain poses that
don’t quite adhere to the physics of a real
human character.
Two, it is possible that the upper body does
something that makes sense, the lower body
also does something that makes sense, but
the whole thing, put together, does not make
too much sense anymore.
Or, three, we may have these foot sliding
artifacts that you see here.
These are more common than you might first
think, here is an example of it from a previous
work, and, look, nearly all of the previous
methods struggle with it.
Now, this new work uses 20 hours of unstructured
training data.
Now, remember, the previous one only used
3, so we rightfully expect that by using more
information, it can also learn more.
But the previous work was already amazing,
so, what more can we really expect this new
one to do?
Well, it can not only learn these motions,
weave together these motions like previous
works, but, hold on to your papers, because
it can now also come up with novel moves as
well!
Wow.
This includes new attacking sequences, and
combining already existing attacks with novel
footwork patterns.
And it does all this spectacularly well.
For instance, if we show it how to have its
guard up, and how to throw a punch, what will
it learn?
Get this, it will keep its guard up while
throwing that punch.
And it not only does that in a realistic,
fluid movement pattern, but it also found
out about something that has strategic value.
Same with evading an attack with some head
movement and counterattacking.
Loving it.
But how easy is it to use this?
Do we need to be an AI scientist to be able
to invoke these amazing motions?
Well, if you have been holding on to your
papers so far, now, squeeze that paper, and
look here.
Wow.
You don’t need to be an AI scientist to
play with this!
Not at all!
All you need is a controller to invoke these
beautiful motions.
And all this runs in real time.
My goodness!
For instance, you can crouch down and evade
a potential attack by controlling the right
stick, and launch a punch in the meantime.
Remember, not only both halves have to make
sense separately, the body motion has to make
sense as a whole.
And it really does, look at that.
And here comes the best part, you can even
assemble your own signature attacks, for instance,
perform that surprise spinning backfist, an
amazing spin kick, and, yes!
You can even go full Karate Kid with that
crane kick.
And as a cherry on top, the characters can
also react to the strikes, clinch, or even
try a takedown.
So, with that, there we go, we are again,
one step closer to having access to super
realistic motion techniques for virtual characters,
and all we need for this is a controller.
And remember, all this already runs in real
time!
Another amazing SIGGRAPH paper from Sebastian
Starke.
And get this, he is currently a 4th year PhD
student and already made profound contributions
to the industry.
Huge congratulations on this amazing achievement.
What a time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!